je dit Gaby
président Président c'est lui le futur
présidenti
futur est-ce que vous êtes dépolitisé
comme on le dit est-ce que la politique
traditionnelle vous intéresse encore moi
je crois pas vraiment à cette idée de de
dépolitisation de notre génération qui
est souvent avancée dans les médias ou
dans certains ouvrages je crois que
effectivement aujourd'hui notre
génération vote un peu moins que
précédemment prochain précédent scrutin
mais mais les jeunes ont toujours été la
la classe d'âge qui votait le moins dans
toutes les élections depuis le début de
la 5è R public je crois simplement que
aujourd'hui c'est plus dur pour nous par
rapport à la génération de nos parents
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord avec la
chute du mur de Berlin les les
différentes les différents repères
identitaires sont moins netes qu'il
l'était avant pour s'engager ouais et
ensuite je crois aussi que le fait
d'aller voter de se rendre aux urnes il
faut le corrél avec le moment où on
entre dans la société et où finalement
on passe du jeune au jeunes adulte on va
dire qui a son qui a un emploi qui
travaille et qui donc se sent actif dans
la société veut et contribuer or
aujourd'hui voilà on a 23 % de chômage
chez les jeunes 40 % dans certaines dans
lieu euh c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
de se sentir investi dans la société et
de pouvoir contribuer mais je crois pas
que les jeunes soient dépolitisés
absolument pas les jeunes je pense ont
plus de conviction que jamais et on les
a vu dans la rue au moment du CPE on les
a vu dans la rue au moment de Jean-Marie
Le Pen au second tour et je crois que
après c'est un engagement qui prend de
diverses for mais je l'ai vu quand je
suis allé à à Marseille rencontrer les
altaes mondialistes on s'engage dans des
associations peut-être plus que est-ce
qu'il ferait un bon politique moi je v
moi je vai pour lui dire j'ai dit j'ai
dit Gaby
président Président c'est lui le futur
président fut ouais donc ces images
vaent très très cher il nous a déjà
[Musique]
attribué